how are you Joe I'm doing great rich
thanks for having me come on man
I always will have you on your in any
time guests as they say what do you
think of what the Cleveland Browns are
up to right now Joseph what do you think
well it'll definitely be an interesting
offseason as we say that a lot about the
Browns but I think for brown fans like
myself the future couldn't be brighter
when you've got a young franchise
quarterback like we have in Baker
Mayfield you've got the best young pass
rusher in the league with Miles Garrett
you got one of the best young
quarterbacks in league with dens award
there's gonna be a lot of coaches that
are gonna be lining up to show up in
Cleveland and interview for that job
yeah well I mean unless Greg Williams
just gets it without an interview
because that's what he says he usually
gets right Joe well of course he does
him and this might be notice really as a
head coach
these showed pretty well so far they
played their best game of the season
last week Baker Mayfield only missed
three passes to go with his three
touchdown passes so the teams playing
well for him you can't argue with the
results
what do you what would you say about
tonight's game you just heard the poll
question who needs it more packer
Seahawks what do you think Joe honestly
I think the Packers do they're they're
really an entire need to win because
their expectations were a lot higher
going into this season and I think the
ship starts to sink and the turmoil gets
a little bit too tough for Mike McCarthy
if they're now not able to win this game
and as a player that's been in that
situation a long time where you start
getting asked more and more about the
future of your coach it becomes
something that's almost more difficult
and insurmountable to overcome and I
think that's going to be the storyline
going forward if they're not able to win
this game do you think there is
something going on with Aaron Rodgers
and Mike McCarthy it certainly seems
like it's the most passive-aggressive
relationship in the NFL to me yeah and
things during the week kind of thinly
veiled a little bit taking shots at Mike
McCarthy and and sort of his coaching
style and I think the problem is you
know when you've been together with
somebody so long you get a little bit of
ordinary towards each other when things
aren't going the way you expected and
maybe Aaron is starting to think hey I
wish we were doing things a little bit
more like I think we
should and it's got a little pence right
there especially being four four and one
like they are right now okay who's the
best team in the league do you think Joe
so you're Thomas what do you think well
it's hard for me to argue with the
Chiefs I mean they're so explosive right
now on offense but I can't wait to watch
them on Monday Night Football because
what a great test going against the Rams
and a little bit of unusual
circumstances being that the game was
supposed to be in Mexico and now it's
gonna be played in LA but I wouldn't I
wouldn't count against as the Chiefs
right now okay what about the Saints
what do you think about them I like to
think - I would put them number two
actually right behind the Chiefs I think
their defense is really solid but to me
even though I I love drew Brees I think
Patrick mahomes the way that often is
something the way that they can beat you
so many different ways in the way
Patrick mahomes can kind of get outside
the pocket and move I give them just a
little bit of an advantage over where
the Saints are right now Joe Thomas here
in the Rich Eisen show what did I'm sure
you saw the video and if not we can put
up on the screen I'll describe for you
Steelers teammates of levy on bail
rummaging through his belongings in the
locker room mere moments after levy on
bail it was announced that he wasn't
coming back I mean just the day after
that happens and they're going through
his stuff even if it was in jest I mean
what do you think of that Joe I think it
was a terrible look and I've been on the
Steelers teammates side a little bit
more than probably most people I feel
that you know what lay beyond Belt did I
think it's hurting himself giving up 14
million this year in hopes that you're
gonna make more than that next year so I
was kind of on the teammates side a
little bit but that's just a bad look
you know why would you ever go through
somebody's stuff like that even though
if he doesn't want it I mean that's
still a stuff that's his personal area
and if everybody in that locker room
wants sympathy they're not gonna get it
very much right now being that you're
just gonna go take the dudes stuff that
just seems wrong yeah even if they were
just joking about it and then did put it
in a box and then send it back to him
it's it kind of gives a glimpse in my
mind of what Mike Tomlin is trying to
hold together and does to the tune of
six to one it's unbelievable
well that's a good point I mean maybe
Mike Talman should be getting a heck of
a lot more credit than he is right now
for being able to put that roster
together and they're playing some great
football I mean they might be the best
team in the AFC right now when you look
at how well they've been playing defense
and the way their offense is something
so give my job and a lot of credit
because it seems like they got a lot of
interesting folks in the locker room and
like eventually that just it kind of
makes my skin crawl a little bit
thinking that they would just go through
somebody's personal stuff even if it was
a joke all right tell me what what
you're doing to gather with the Polaris
Ranger what does heroes hunt Joe hunt is
a great program it's developed to
celebrate veterans and raise awareness
and funding for this awesome place
called leek hunting and mountain
preserve which is out in Pennsylvania I
got a chance to go out there and spend
the day with some veterans and it's it's
offering veterans a place for them and
their families to heal by using hunting
fishing and outdoor recreation and Leake
is aiming to raise a hundred thousand
dollars so that they can expand on them
all which is like the really cool
lodging and meeting area where all these
veterans they come in with their
different wounds and their injuries and
they get together and they break bread
they spend time together they get that
team feel that they had when they are in
the military and now as they're trying
to come back to civilian life and
reintegrate so it's a great thing that
leakes doing and it's a great thing that
Polaris is doing trying to help leek
raise that money for that expansion and
how can anybody take part in this sort
of thing so yeah so the first thing you
should do is go to leek preserve org
that's le EK preserve org that will give
you an idea of how cool leek is and all
the great things that they're doing for
our veterans all the hundreds of
veterans that lives are being changed
for the better at leek and then that'll
also give you an opportunity to click on
different links and see where you can go
and donate and make a difference for
this great organization and then you're
still doing the tomahawk show on LeBrons
platform uninterrupted right you and
Andrew Hawkins you know when you've got
an Emmy Award winning and Oscar
nominated pod
like the tomahawk show the other thing
doesn't go away it just keeps getting
bigger we actually had two awesome
guests on this week that were a lot of
fun Melvin Ingram from the Chargers the
most underrated outside linebacker in
the league and then we had our good
friend and tomahawk fan Eric Weddle
what a great personality that guy is
although he did shave his beard which
made me mad yeah he did shave his beard
and first of all news to me they give
out Emmys and Oscars to podcasts because
where was where were our nominations
back in the day I know that's number one
yeah I like it though joke if you had a
better podcast you're just not in that
rarefied air like I am you know what Joe
you're right podcasts better is what is
is is the message right there correct
but the the news that just hit of Eric
Weddle steam it looks with Joe Flacco
and Lamar Jackson not able to practice
on this here Thursday that the Baltimore
Ravens coming off of their bye week this
very week taking on the Baltimore Ravens
are taking on the Bengals at home and a
huge game that your former teammate one
of the million quarterbacks that you
protected in Cleveland rg3 is going to
get an opportunity here I wonder what
you think of that Joe yeah you know what
I I think they're just thrown smoke show
up there right there it's just a smoke
screen it's the Bill Belichick he'd
rather have nobody practice and make the
opponent wonder who the quarterback is
rather than get out on that field and
try to get better so who is that gonna
what who are they hiding the smoke show
of lamar jackson is what you're saying
well no no i think what you're gonna see
is lamar jackson go out there but they
don't want to put anything on tape for
that media that first 10 minutes the
practice that they get to watch they
they just want to keep everybody
guessing going into Sunday whoo what
what if rg3 does get the opportunity
what do you think about that having been
around you do a great job yeah I think I
think Robert will do an outstanding job
that guy control the ball a mile he's a
winner back from his days in Washington
and I think he just needs another
opportunity I think he definitely has a
chance to still make a good career in
this league you take care of yourself
Joe Thomas ok thanks for the call
I know you got you got other stuff going
on today
appreciate you chime in and pal hey
Richard I do appreciate you allowing me
to come on the show and talk about all
the great things that leek is doing but
also the oscar-nominated well this this
conversation is going to be submitted
for an Emmy
so I appreciate already in advance you
got it Joe Thomas I've been called
Richard and Rick by guests so far this
week I know the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience